hello youtubers subscribers viewers
everyone welcome to another ht tutorial
in this video i'll be showing you a
quick way to encode any video that you
create
in hd so the first thing we're going to
do is open a very very simple
unbelievably stupid uh windows movie
maker it's a an extremely easy uh movie
editing program so i'm just going to
open it up it'll open up full screen as
you can see now i have my introduction i
already uploaded this video so i'll
delete it so
the easiest thing to do if you want to
encode and open a movie in hd to watch
it in the highest um the highest
pixelation possible that it can actually
render the movie in go ahead and drag it
to the actual timeline and it's just my
introduction for now which you saw at
the beginning of this video what i'm
going to click is the publish movie
button so this is going to publish it to
my computer for playback i can also put
it on a dvd in the highest quality
possible i can send it to an email in
the highest quality possible or actually
send it to a camera and it's and it's sd
card in the highest quality possible so
i'm going to push this to my computer go
ahead and double click that or hit this
button
next what i'm going to do is just name
the movie um
just my introduction so i'll name it
exactly that and select a folder that
you can actually trust that you want to
encode and send this high quality movie
to so i'm going to send it to the my
videos folder or you could select the
browse button and choose whatever folder
you want go ahead and hit next and this
is the most important part choose the
settings for your movie this determines
the quality and file size of your movie
now i've heard a lot of people saying
that their videos actually come out to
an extremely large size which i can
actually fix for you guys i'm still
looking into that but what i've chosen
right now says best quality for playback
on your computer that is recommended but
not by me i'm going to hit the more
settings button
as you can see it's by default dvi pal
i'm going to click that and go down to
720p
there are two settings right below that
are actually better than this but i'm
going to say 720p because number one
that's what i upload all my videos in
and it's the highest quality possible
playback settings in youtube
if you upload any video in any quality
higher than 720p or 5.9 per second it's
not going to translate if you do upload
in um the xbox 360 format hd format it
will come out to 6.9 megabytes per
second and even 1080p at
7.7.8 megabytes per second is going to
be the highest possible bandwidth that
you can actually encode your movie in so
i encoding 720p for the highest
uploading quality and as you can see
down here it'll change to 1280 1280x720
resolution and it'll be a 16x9 aspect
ratio and 25 frames per second and i'll
just say the settings for xbox 360. it's
actually going to be a little bit better
sound 6.9 megabytes per second nothing
else changed then i'll go to 1080p which
will actually change it to seven point
seven point megabytes per second and a
1440 by 1080 resolution
which is a 16x9 aspect ratio so in order
to publish it all you have to do is
select your format and hit the publish
button and that is it it will encode the
in the entire movie in the highest
possible quality and then when you go to
upload it to youtube or show to your
friends then that is exactly the movie
that you're going to upload
and it will translate to youtube in the
highest possible quality and you can
watch it in hd just like you might have
done the video so thanks for watching
tutorial and i hope you found it helpful
if you have any other tutorial requests
just go ahead and subscribe and send me
a message and i will do my best thanks
for watching guys peace
you